en este vídeo vamos a trabajar un nuevo
ejercicio de recta de regresión Y
también vamos a conocer vamos a poder
unir los temas que vimos junto con el
coeficiente de determinación para eso
vamos a tener unos puntos vamos a tener
el punto menos
uno menos uno vamos a tener el punto
menos dos menos tres que está acá menos
dos menos tres vamos a tener el punto 1
1 2 y vamos a tener el punto 4 3
el punto 4 3
con estos puntos vamos a averiguar
entonces la recta de regresión para eso
si tenemos que averiguar m que como
sabemos es igual a xy Barra menos x
barra por y barra sobre
x o la media de los X cuadrados menos
el cuadrado del x barra de la media de
los X y que B es igual a la media de la
si menos m el valor que consigamos de m
por el de X barra vamos a tener que
averiguar el valor tanto de X barra como
de Ibarra como de X por y barra como de
X cuadrado barra para eso vamos a
trabajar
x barra es igual a la suma de todos los
X de cada uno de los puntos es decir
menos dos menos uno más uno más cuatro
todo dividido 4 y esto es igual a un
medio
el valor de Ibarra es igual a menos 3
menos 1 + 2 + 3 todo dividido 4 y esto
es igual a un cuarto el valor de X y
barra es igual a la multiplicación vamos
a bajar un poco de menos 2 por menos 3
más menos uno por menos uno más
uno por dos más cuatro vamos a correr un
poco más más 4 por 3 todo dividido 4
Y esto es igual a 21 cuartos vamos a ir
copiando en limpio todos estos datos
tenemos que este es un medio
tenemos que la media de todas las y
es igual a un cuarto
vamos a borrar este tenemos finalmente
que la media de todos los X por y es
igual a 21 cuartos y nos falta averiguar
Ahora sí falta averiguar
el valor de la media de las x cuadradas
es igual Esto entonces
A menos 2 al cuadrado más menos uno al
cuadrado más 1 al cuadrado más 4 al
cuadrado todo dividido
Y esto es igual a
11/2 tenemos finalmente
que esto es igual a 11/2
ahora sí tenemos todos los datos
necesarios para poder calcular el valor
de m
si bajamos un poco
vamos a poder calcular que M es igual
a 21 cuartos
menos
un medio por un cuarto que esto lo saco
de los datos de acá verdad tenemos que
esto es igual a 21/4 esto por esto es
igual a esto por esto
que tenemos ahí y todo esto hay que
dividirlo
por 11 medios menos el cuadrado del
medio de las x que es igual a un medio
al cuadrado
esto es igual vamos a trabajar un poco
tenemos
21 cuartos menos un medio por un cuarto
es un octavo
más dividido 11 medios menos un cuarto
ahora 21/4 es igual a 42 octavos menos
un octavo 11 medios es igual a 22
cuartos menos un cuarto para que hago
esto para poder llevar todos a un mismo
denominador
finalmente o no finalmente sino en el
otro paso Vamos a tener 41 octavos sobre
cuartos Y si dividimos 41 octavos
dividido 21/4 es lo mismo que
multiplicar esto por 4 sobre 21
que al simplificar este me quedan dos
este me queda en uno 21 por 2 es igual a
41 sobre 42 el valor de m finalmente
Ahora sí finalmente
es igual a
42 y de esta forma podemos calcular el
valor de B
B vamos a poner M es igual y b es igual
a Ibarra que es un cuarto
menos
41 sobre 42
por x barra que es un medio
Y esto es igual a menos 5
menos 5 es un 5 bastante raro muy
parecido a ese menos 5 sobre 21
tenemos así
vamos a escribir lo más prolijo menos
5 sobre 21 tenemos de esta forma el
valor de m y el valor de B por lo tanto
podemos decir que la recta de regresión
es igual
y igual a 41 sobre 42 x menos 5 sobre 21
Y esta es nuestra recta de regresión
la tan buscada recta de regresión si la
gráficamos vamos a obtener Algo similar
a esto
vamos a bajar
vamos a tener algo así
graficada la recta de regresión tenemos
algo así y vamos a poder notar que los
errores son Realmente muy cercanos
algunos casi nulos
la distancia de los puntos a la recta
son Realmente muy cercanas y esta es la
recta óptima la recta de regresión
que es igual ahí igual a 41 sobre 42 x
menos
5 sobre 21 vamos a borrar todo lo otro
para no generar confusión
vamos a borrar acá esto
vamos a borrar
para no generar confusión tenemos
finalmente la recta nuestra recta de
regresión
expresada por la siguiente ecuación
pero ahora si quisiéramos conseguir el
coeficiente de determinación Tendremos
que hacer unos cálculos mucho más
engorrosos que no vamos a realizarlos en
este vídeo sino que vamos a utilizar un
vídeo más adelante que se los recomiendo
ver que vamos a poder trabajar con esta
misma expresión con estos mismos datos
sobre un sobre una sobre un coeficiente
de determinación